any second any second ten seconds until
kickoff 63 players at this point nearly
19-hundred here we go nearly 19-hundred
rated shark club 88 this is Cillian okay
I have this square I have that dark
square and I am going to get rid of this
night and then make sure that I could
jump into that d4 point I think I'm I
think I'm okay with giving up my dark
square Bishop Paul can't move I have
pressure on this that's deadly just like
that the queen is gone she is gone and
just don't just don't leave my knight
that's the plan open this position up
they resigned back to tournament two
three two two a lot of time
chicks mean alright
gambit how often do I play a gambit not
often I have a center now as a result I
have a good center and I could be
looking for tricks on this square my
opponent is preventing that it's just
castle not the most aggressive post for
my dark square bishop I want to get my
dark square Bishop and Queen on this
diagonal okay they're not doing anything
about that I could jump my knight in
here let's open it up open this position
up Oh at this Queen first and then
my bishop on this diagonal there might
be some tricks against this point I
didn't want to see that all right we're
gonna I'm gonna give up my dark square
bishop clearly clearly the dark square
bishop scam but I have this okay let's
try to get this trade again it's
probably going to be avoided really this
knight Knight takes pawn is maybe there
okay now I want to sneak my queen in
pawn pushes no I could still take bishop
here get rid of that dark square Bishop
is the plan Bishop back it's made on a
che you can't avoid it at this point so
look up and over as the next plan rook
up and over sac on g6 look up rook over
this rook is hanging I don't want to
clean trade oh I was ready to just drop
something there okay now not cool okay
they don't have any time oh I just tried
to jump a piece oh my goodness I don't
have any time I don't have any time oh
my goodness where did my time go ah man
I don't have any time I have to pre move
the rest of this game
oh my goodness
oh I'm down oh where did my time go I
was trying to get some crazy attack it
was never there
oh man okay you got a recover I have to
launch each pawns and everything now
launch each pawns time to launch each
pawns I have to go against my my comfort
zone
I'm sorry play queen here that would've
been too comfortable for my queen okay
that bishops dead ah man just like that
just like that down Forks though hang on
I'm at zero zero is a terrible score
come on you could do it you could do it
you could do it don't you dare start
giving up I got the Queen got the Queen
oh man that was should have been so much
easier shouldn't have there we go that's
what I'm talking about
get back on that plus side man four I
got a mountain to climb
can he do it can he do it okay am i
playing on tilt
I've been through worse I'd been through
worst I've had to UM I've had to recover
from a laughing fit before he was there
to see that the bishops dead he's not
around to see that we're bad jokes on my
opponent disconnected ah man they wanted
none of that they cared that much about
their Bishop they had a disconnect okay
Who am I gonna be tracking down let's
see I have to do some home cooking home
cooking where are the pack leaders where
are they this guy is up there with the
beefy 27 geez this guy needs to slow
down 27 come on white man oh my goodness
root okay 25 more seconds I gotta wait
this could still be pretty good a fairly
quick win this will boost me up to what
ah man right in my tracks what'd I win
the first game and then the next one
down down on time oh I tried to jump
over my piece to in that one position
that's when you know you're not having a
good game they started jumping over
pieces with rooks back to tournament ten
where the pack leaders 27 12 okay I got
a long way to go
this guy else slapped me around if I'm
not careful very easily submission to
cough again now let's try this all right
stop that advanced in that night maybe
stop it stop it right now
okay I'm winning that pond it's scary
though take another one whoa I can't
leave here whoa scary town scary town oh
my goodness oh my goodness well I got to
take the Queen this is so bad this is so
bad
I think I could take the bishop I think
I can I think I can I hope I can I hope
I hope yeah come on I need to save
where's the save is this a safe take
this first I gotta I gotta I gotta win
this one on time to give a check and
then I get a pawn back I think I get one
of the ponds which ones are gonna be oh
boy I'm in trouble
I'm in big trouble I'm in big trouble
oh this is not where my king wants to my
wreck wants to be I'm so dead
he should have kept pushing right it's
still dead for me could I sneak around
it this way
I can't save this can you
this is unsavable it's unsavable this
pawn going cut the King off somehow get
this defend that sneak over with the
king
it's not looking good oh I lost my rook
I didn't time situation
I'm down a time one day at one second oh
I'm at six your norm at eight you can't
recover from that that's two losses too
too quickly come on you could do it you
could do it let's go ah okay I need some
crazy tricks I was saying this before
this is Groundhog Day Groundhog Day who
knows what I'm talking about I'm
chopping a pond oh I got this fish up
he's cooked he's cooked this happened
earlier didn't it brac out a bishop like
that was it in this tournament
can I get castled for once feel like I
wasn't canceled in that last game all my
piece is working kill this piece where's
the Queen going I'm dropping this or am
i 32 seconds ah the Knights gonna kill
me okay
okay these guys are coming on V in check
there you go there's a fork it's gonna
get pinned though I could break the pin
then I'm on the rook I'm on the Queen
take the Queen she's free she's been
free oh my goodness was that a free
queen that's a Pokemon where's the maid
where's the main get me maids back to
tournament 16 you can't come back from
this can you 51 is it possible no way
it's never been done before I have to
run like the wind blows I have to go
into Forrest Gump mode Forrest Gump mode
to catch that a little trick that I do
there even if it isn't funny I'd throw a
little laugh right at the end it makes
you more uncut more inclined to laugh
that's the that's the trick right there
that's the trick my knight is a monster
he's a monster I have to run like the
wind blows man
all right I'm looking to UM kill that
bishop I have to watch over this pawn
though I need a babysitter
I must mouse slip to f4 I would not have
been good all right let's get these
pawns running Bishop takes Knight is a
threat mate threat queen is dead mate
until a look f2 and then here they're
gonna resign they resigned back to term
in twenty-six hang on
I'm moving up the ranks I'm going down
though oh my goodness watch out for the
Queen d4 pawn push night here Bishop g4
we've seen it before
quick resigner ah might be quick
resigned no it's not watch Bishop here
did I call that one why did I take with
my clean somebody tell me that somebody
tell me that Oh winning a pawn that's
too crazy no it's not oh it's not Bishop
check knight is pinned it's got to be
scary all right let's keep them pinned
and then jump in the knight has to go
there open the position up keep your
opponent pinned deadly fork and let's
just take pieces can i rescue my knight
need to rescue my knight is it being
rescued is he gonna be rescued castle
pawn push
just push
on the bishop no checks with the bishop
okay finally my knight is doing
something what's my rook doing nothing
my rook is garbage keep my pawns on
light no tricky tactics okay my rook I
could function on these light squares
now they resigned back to term at 38
hang on
67 42 42 38 come on you can you do it
can you do it 17 minutes remaining we're
not even at the halfway point this guy
might wait a second he's an on mover
blue flame this could be good
he moved I need a fishing pole I need a
fishing pole to uh really back in there
reel me back in keep that night away get
on the C file I need to retreat for my
night I want to jump into c4 whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa all right the
Queen's are off my opponent has three
pawns let's trade a little bit oh man
this is so scary so scary if I did I did
the King move right away
I think Bishop here kills me I think
okay some trades might what am i doing I
look here I get some stuff that pond is
hard to defend actually very hard to
defend Bishop chat could that be
annoying okay we're having this so my
lights bishop bishop check might have
been an important move so I'm getting
some of these pawns I'm looking to get
these these pawns rolling very soon
maybe I could get this pawn first I
think King here would have picked up
something came over to defend get my
pawns rolling bring my knight over here
Knight check okay
keep pushing my pony isn't moving
okay they're down on time back to
Chairman sixty-five 59 58 nobody's
running away with it nobody's running
away with it so I have a chance we're at
the halfway point how am i how am I I
have to lot maybe there's other people
have one loss okay
can I do something with my light square
bishop I'm gonna try to do something I
could have considered just pinning that
it's doing now structural damage Knight
here actually if you take then I have
some tricky stuff against the clean
actually this is probably a good idea
that's check oh no man they missed h7
it's exactly what I needed who's in
first 1665 just like that
don't blink do not blink whatever you do
here we go let's go here let's go here
oh this guy's not moving he is moving I
have the same reaction every time when
my opponent is not moving this night
could be a problem I have a space
advantage space advantage get the light
square Bishop out and then kill my pawn
on the light squares remove that
defender capture like this I want to
keep control over this square capture
the bishop looking for me very very soon
that Knights not a good defender is he
we're gonna see very shortly
let's check where is the mate am I gonna
make this time that feels right that
feels even more right the queen is dead
get back here I don't want you to escape
over here that's exactly what's gonna
happen let's just castle no matter what
let's throw a check-in where is the main
Queen here is mate ah where is that mate
yeah no matter what check mate next
probably missed a ton of mates
that's me back to tournament 86-83 77
excuse me sorry about that
okay Steve for 13 minutes remaining um
okay some some gambit I don't know that
this is a good idea cuz I'm able to
still get a center okay now I have a
very strong center my bishop is pointing
right at their King I'm gonna look to
expand very shortly here we go
shut that diagonal down get on this
diagonal h7 again I could take this pawn
they're not not doing that now doing
that okay this night away oh my goodness
is my Queen trapped close to it okay
that Knights dead
pawn takes with check my voice is
cracking up with Czech queen is dead he
is dead width check another check and
then I can rescue my light square bishop
I'm looking for me now okay I want my
Queen to be right here
are they gonna move it's not my move
it's me very soon
pawn push pawn up rook here filed by me
now there's something even faster Bishop
here okay they resigned back to
tournament one else 107 107 106 84 11
minutes card Fisher what is the vestnik
have no need to cash in on one of these
need to cash in everybody knows about
this now everybody knows about it I'm
still going for Bishop here I have to do
this all right I'm not sure what that's
doing sneaky stuff Bishop here it's the
material the rook I have this covered
just take this pawn they're coming back
there okay let's get on this diagonal
jump my knight in here actually support
this swing like lean over that night is
boxed out only because of this pawn
watch over this square that night spin
how can i attack them open the position
up my opponent is pinned let me get over
here first over here even better okay my
dark square Bishop needs to do something
else it's a little bit too scary for my
tastes here still have everything
covered Bishop here I'll just take it
okay they resigned back determine 126
107 10 minutes remaining
oh man let's try efore efore and maybe
some Grand Prix no okay okay watch out
for Bishop g4 lost my queen more than
once they played that move too quick so
tango going on d3 castle h3 night h2 f4
see if this works
actually let me pick up this as soon as
the night played there obstructing the
bishop I should have considered that
alright let's see if my opponent giving
you that light square bishop okay and
let's get these pawns going now to
protect okay well let's do this get the
a file it might clean out to f3 that's
the primary reason I want to maintain
this pawn if takes I want to keep
control over this square maybe Knight
into this square Knight to h6 reinforce
this point I'm just winning that pond or
that Bishop on the rook as well my
Knights gonna get kicked around
he is getting kicked around a little bit
on this pawn I could have taken this for
a while now to reinforce this one more
time and I have this square covered in
case the knight wants to jump in there
but let's make sure he doesn't come over
here either
he's ready to just chop everything up
here but I could defend now probably had
some fork over here what takes pawn next
okay never mind change of plans let's
trade trading is better King safety
first nothing else is going on King
safety I've secured my king position and
now I want to get my knight right in
here right in here is a good spot and
what more my knight back there down on
time back to tournament 146 127 123
eight minutes remaining
okay 14 games in 13 games in all right
all right I like I like this situation
where I could get that move in with
tempo and now I have a space advantage
and I want to secure this pond just like
that and remove this bishop that's going
to be my plan get rid of any block hater
of that past pond so how can I do that
let's put pressure on this Knight first
I clean up I'm needing more support for
this pond keep my opponent in a pin for
as long as possible and Knight here I
should have maybe been considering that
and now it's all the more appealing and
the queen is close to trapped after this
rook is the bishops gonna move next pawn
push is available soon and I probably
should have moved it it could have been
taken just then I'm gonna move it next
let's move it now shut my knight in here
bishop here actually okay two bishops
deadly diagonal is a passed pawn the
rook is hit and I want my rook on the
e-file and it has a support point was it
addressed to watch out for back rank
mates my bishop is blocking things up
they resigned 166 143 six minutes
remaining Andrew I didn't mean to do
that we're gonna have to work with it
though aren't we kill that night I
should have done it sooner when I could
have had structural damage reinforced my
knight
I keep piling up on that okay
where's the attack where is that attack
here's the attack my goodness my part is
flying out of here my knight has a good
square there Bishop is shut down and I
want to avoid what exactly I want to
avoid the opening up of files so Bishop
g5 I just dropped back should have
considered maybe the other one sink my
knight my um I rooks in these dark
squares I want to do that
okay okay and now next order of business
is what get my Queen active in this side
of the board okay my knight is very
tricky I should have taken that pot how
many times this time I'm gonna take him
oh I'm on that hon I've given that up to
get rid of this pun okay he was a number
one priority for sure he was a number
one priority where is the me seems like
it's close to happening get this pond
clean check here at this pawn with check
my opponent is very fast I have to watch
out by determine I want on time I think
I don't know if they resigned 186 164
four minutes remaining
rot rot cod oh this guy is negative 23
he's gonna play now though he's gonna
play now that was he resigning maybe
just having a tough day tough day at the
office that happens it definitely
happens keep the pin my opponent wants
to break it they need to move their
bishop no they're dropping their queen
then I resign I'm not resigning complete
my development I don't care about
winning any more material did all my
pieces working stay on an open file get
my bishop working get castled maybe just
take here one day okay they resigned
back to chairman 206
206 186 357 oh I almost fell slip that
again French defense you know war nope
okay this is a weak point my plan is to
target this pawn with everything first
the bishop I don't care about doubled
pawns do not care about that pile up on
this keep pieces pinned and let's take
him otherwise he jumps in here
pile up in this pond he's going down
soon and I think pressure here first
pressure on the night mm-hmm
repair my pawn structure okay my knight
has a good square good night versus bad
bishop I have to watch out for this mate
I want to blunt that diagonal with f3
just in case and next up maybe kill the
bishop he's running way short on squares
and I'm gonna win material bishop here I
take with interest with the fork okay
they're getting something in return for
it keep my structure as is keep my
knight right where he's at
it's a great defender my rook on a
half-open file pile up and defend my
knight is a really good defender of that
of Queen check okay get out there it's a
flight square and so I'm
get out of there she's too close too
close for me keep going with these pawns
what am i doing am i doing now get out
of there nothing but trouble nothing but
trouble Queen takes pawn here why am i
leaving that Queen gets so active okay
let's do this you could take the pawn at
sea okay finally can I get something
going out here Queen check I probably
had a knight checkmate I did
oh my goodness where's my time
you kidding me get back here oh my
goodness I thought I was running out of
time
Oh 226 206 one minute 33 I don't know if
this one will finish this is it's the
last game last game all right
I keep this around get out of that the
Queen check might be okay let's do this
hang that hang on to that guy
it's my light Oh doing that I need it oh
that was almost the adobe flash gambit
did you see it did you see that one wow
this is not good maybe it is can I get
me a tricky night he's way way too
tricky way way too tricky somehow seems
good night here now get the Queen at
least where does that mean night here I
could get the Queen just giving check
night here bishop checkmate where's that
mean may here next that's me
that's what I needed back to chairman
246 I didn't need that one let's whoo 46
to 44 man
that guy still wins who's in second it's
been assigned I think I got it I think I
saw the ax cube it's a signed first oh
oh man a buzzer-beater sort of I'll take
those buzzer beaters whoo all right good
games oh not a squeaky-clean tournament
at all 246 244 210 204 201 201 200 was a
tight pack up there for third place
could have been anyone's right there
all right good
Oh